hi this is Dr Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason I O
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught Philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
I come in
to help students and lifelong Learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to YouTube many
viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos each
of them focused on One Core concept from
an important philosophical text I hope
you find it useful as well
in these section of the Soma theologiai
uh first part of the second part
question 46 where Thomas Aquinas is
turning to look at anger as such or de
Euro secundum say he's going to begin
with a consideration that we might find
a bit abstract and even strange and the
question is
is anger a what we're going to call
specific emotion
specularis and so the contrast here is
between anger as a specific or special
or particular emotion versus being a
general generalis pacio right it's a
general emotion that would somehow
Encompass others and given Thomas's
psychology it kind of makes sense that
this would be a concern because remember
for Saint Thomas
we have the appetite and that is divided
into the concupiscent appetite and into
the irascible or contentious appetite
and that's named after anger itself so
he begins with as he usually does some
arguments against the point that he
wants to make so the very first one has
to do with the irascible or contending
appetite it runs it seems that anger is
not a specific emotion why not the
contending appetite derives its name
from anger so we have anger as an
emotion and then we have anger or the
contending appetite as a broader set of
of drives that would be named after this
particular emotion so it seems like if
that's the case then all these other
emotions that fall under it hope despair
things like that are
connected to anger in some way he says
there's many contending emotions not
just one hence anger era is not a
specific or particular emotion so that's
one argument that we'll look at the
second one says and this is very
interesting each particular emotion has
its contrary but we saw from earlier in
the summer Taylor yeah anger is kind of
unique in that it doesn't have a
contrary emotion Thomas is very
insistent on this
um being not angry is not an emotion
itself right the way that it is say an
Aristotle's rhetoric calmness or
mildness or something like that Thomas
says anger doesn't have any contrary
emotions so
logically this should mean that anger is
not a specific or particular emotion and
then the third one that's again very
very interesting as well a specific
emotion does not include any other but
anger includes a number of emotions
um sadness tristium
um delight delectatio and hope spay
right so
space actually
how can anger be a particular emotion if
it actually includes these other
emotions and again this goes all the way
back to Aristotle as well who defined
anger as you know in the very definition
including pain and also just a little
bit after that in the rhetoric as
involving pleasure and the pleasure
comes from the hope of revenging or
retaliating or retribution so these are
some interesting arguments that Thomas
thinks are worth taking seriously and
the way in which he's going to make
sense of this is by introducing some
distinctions and it's notable that here
Thomas as so does sometimes Aristotle
will say well there's two kinds of
things oh and by the way there's a third
as well so that's precisely what happens
here he says there's two kinds of
generality which we can translate as
logical and causal into English the
Latin is actually pair
practicationum so in accordance with how
things are predicated of each other this
is going to have to do with the sort of
logical structure of species and genus
right how things fit into
classifications and then there's causal
percosum right so that's pretty
straightforward and then there's going
to be a third so let's look at the first
two he says there's two kinds of
generality logical and causal so what's
an example of logical animal is a
logical or predication genus so we fit
into animal human being right and
squirrels fit into that as do mollusks
which mollusks include a whole bunch of
other things right and so we could we
can arrange things in this way can we do
this with the emotions
yes and no I mean we can certainly talk
about some of the emotions being
emotions of the concupiscible appetite
right and others of the irascible
appetite we're already doing some
logical structure there what's an
example of causality working here he
says the Sun as Dennis says is a general
cause of all Earthly generative
processes so in a certain way this is a
typical Thomas Aquinas the effects are
included in the cause in this case the
Sun and everything that takes place
because of the Sun
so he says that a Genus contains many
differences that agree in being and like
material so we can have the genus of
emotion and then we have all these other
you know emotions within them and
they're different from each other uh uh
he goes on and says a causal agent by
its productive power contains a number
of effects but now we get to something
more complicated he says a given effect
may be produced by the convergence of
various causes since there is an every
effect some trace of its cause we can
add a third kind of generality
a third mode of generality and that is
not of the cause that is of the effect
that is produced by a concurrence by a
coming together
in the Latin of of different causes and
diverse is is really how the Latin runs
so we've got three different kinds of
generality and now we can ask ourselves
having made this distinction okay where
does anger fit into this is anger
generic because if it's not particular
it's going to be generic right so does
anger fit this in The Logical sense
no because anger is just one of a number
of different kinds of emotions he says
it's distinct from the other emotions as
we've seen and he says it's not a
general emotion in the second sense that
is by being a cause of other emotions as
a matter of fact it's an effect of other
emotions rather than a Cause
and here Thomas uses an example from
previous discussions in the summit yeah
he says there are some emotions that are
generic in this causal sense love is a
prime example of this right love lies
behind a lot of the other emotions
including anger so in a certain sense
love contains the effects of the other
emotions anger does not what about the
third sense he says
in the third sense we can view anger as
a general emotion which would mean in
that case it's you know uh not said to
be specific insofar as anger is produced
by or includes other emotions he says
it's aroused by the concurrence of
several emotions and he says something
really quite uh worth noting here he
says an angry reaction arises only when
one has endured some pain right so
that's one of the emotions
desires and hopes for Revenge
and he brings up Aristotle he says
Aristotle says an angry man hopes to
inflict punishment that is he wants to
avenge himself
so if the person
realizes or just assumes that because
the other person is so powerful there's
no real hope of attaining Revenge they
don't actually become angry according to
Thomas Aquinas who is following Avid
Senna in this right so that is uh quite
an interesting thing to point out so
anger can in fact be a general emotion
but only insofar as it is produced by a
concurrence of other emotions acting as
causes or constituents of the anger now
how does he address those initial
arguments remember the first argument
had to do with the nature of the
irascible or contending appetite and
aerosol Association Thomas says
something really quite curious here that
it's a little bit hard to to buy into he
says
um
the contending appetite is named from
anger not just because its only reaction
is that of anger right there are other
contending uh emotions
but he says that all of its reactions
terminate in anger and the Latin there
is is very close to the English
Terminator right
so what could this possibly mean do do
hope and despair terminate in Anger lead
to anger that doesn't seem so so it's
not clear what he's actually getting at
the second thing that he says makes a
bit more sense uh he says anger is the
most striking uh or the most manifest
the most open the one that impresses
itself upon the rest of us observing it
of these various contending emotions
inter Alias aeos motus is
most apparent most impressing or
something like that what about the uh
second anger does not have a contrary so
therefore it cannot be a specific
emotion Thomas says anger doesn't have a
contrary distinct from it
why because in it there is contraryity
so it doesn't have an an external
contrary it's already a a tumultuous
composition of contrast including like
pain and pleasure right uh so anger
itself uh is kind of complicated he says
anger is produced by contrary motions by
hope whose object is agreeable and by
sadness whose object is disagreeable and
then he talks about colors here he says
this is kind of like intermediate colors
in which the only contrary it is that of
the pure colors in which they're
composed what does he mean by that well
think about Orange
orange is a composite of uh red and
yellow right it's it's orange is a
complex color or uh we could think about
um
colors that actually like directly
contradict each other red and green
which itself is a complex of yellow and
blue as we know right what do they
produce they produce Brown so Brown
would be like the anger in this case
what about the third argument that was
given here
um
anger involves you know multiple other
emotions and uh Thomas is going to say
yeah I've already addressed that it's
there's a concurrence of multiple causes
here anger involves a number of emotions
not as a Genus does a species so it's
not including all these emotions under
anger but rather as an effect embodies
or includes or is derived from its cause
so it includes these other emotions
which he's naming off you know pain or
sadness
tristia in this case hope and pleasure
or or Delight right so anger can in fact
be rightly understood as a specific
emotion but as one that is produced by
it incorporates other emotions